It's time to play
First Draft Movie Quotes.
Movies are great
not only 'cause they feature
often Tom Hardy doing a weird
accent with his shirt off--
meow-- uh, but also because they
give us very memorable quotes,
from "Life is like a box
of chocolates,"
pretty much anything
from Lebowski.
But all good writing takes work,
and I'm sure some
of those timeless words sucked
before they were great.
So I'd like you to give me
as many first draft movie quotes
as you possibly can.
Examples might be like, uh,
"Life is like a box of (bleep)"
or "Come with me if you want
to continue breathing
and taking oxygen and converting
it into carbon dioxide."
Uh... It was very bad.
The first draft of that
was very bad.
And begin. Jonathan.
I'll have what Meg Ryan's
having, an orgasm.
Nice. Points. Dave Hill.
My name is James Bond.
What's your name?
Points.
Jonathan Coulton.
I'm not literally Spartacus, but
I support what he stands for.
All right, points. Dave Hill.
I really hope these fences
hold up.
After all, it is Jurassic Park.
Yeah, points. Aimee Mann.
This boat is too small
for this big shark.
Yes, points. Points. Dave Hill.
"Murder" backwards.
Uh, Aimee.
It's against regulations
to have snakes on this plane.
Yes, points.
Uh, Jonathan Coulton.
I see dead people.
For instance, you, you're dead.
Points.